[Music]
mary what's going on how are we doing
hi john um thank you for taking my call
i'm really excited to talk to you today
and i'm excited thank you
we'll see they always think i am until
they actually call
so what's up well we'll see um so
i'm looking for some advice on how to
navigate a conversation with my
daughter's
boyfriend's parents um to kind of give
you a little bit of background
yes i think i know it's coming please
tell me i'm right
you're probably right um so she's 16 and
they're all getting this boy
there are no good conversations that
begin with i need help talking to my
daughter's boyfriend's parents you are
absolutely right
it's gonna sound like i'm laughing at
you i promise i'm not but my daughter's
five my time will come but it's not here
yet so i'm with you on this
okay so yeah i interrupted your
daughter's 16th now that's okay
um she is 16 she's been dating a boy for
about six months
and which is like basically forever when
you're 16. it's a thousand years yes
yes so um things are getting or feeling
i guess
pretty serious um she
um had him over last week and
basically what happened is a lot of kids
hold on hold on
you started this call so good so like
all right i need your advice on this
thing that happened here
and now that we're getting closer you're
circling this thing like
like a slow record player in slo-mo it's
like it's unfolding
so then a thing happened at our house
and you know right barry white
was on the record player and all right
so walk me into this here we go
so i was busy with my other kids we were
all together
you know hanging out watching a movie um
i was i got busy with the other kids
and everybody kind of went outside and i
was like okay well it's time for me to
do something
you know around the house so i asked my
daughter and her boyfriend to do
a thing and i thought they went and did
a thing but they did something else oh
they did a thing all right
[Laughter]
so luckily i didn't i didn't actually
visualize the things that happened
um i only heard what happened
and then yeah i think i'd rather
see it than hear it yeah i think she
thought that i was outside
so um i just made it blatantly clear
that i was not outside
and then it was super awkward after that
but i did not confront them or have a
conversation
at that moment um i thought it wouldn't
really be helpful because i was probably
a little emotional and
you know feeling some kind of way um yes
i decided to table that conversation
okay i know it's about to get serious
but so before we take a turn into like
this is actually this is hard i know
this is hard no no parent i know
but i have to know what's the thing you
said
so i didn't say anything to them did you
just make really loud noises
what did you do it honestly just got
very loud like i started to do dishes
and clang things around
you didn't make them you didn't go
charging into the room
no so do they know that you know yes
they are aware so we actually tabled the
conversation he
left not long after that and i just
didn't say anything um
and then my husband and i had a
conversation with our daughter
separately um we're pretty open about
these things we're aware that teenagers
are teenagers and they have hormones and
they're going to do things
yeah and so our daughter wasn't super
uncomfortable to talk about it which is
very odd because i was very
uncomfortable
but we did have a conversation with her
but now i'm wondering
how to go about having a conversation
with a
do i have a conversation with her and
her boyfriend together and
how do i talk to parents about this
because
at some point she's going to need or not
me too but wants to go to his house
and hang out okay and we have to set
some boundaries
and have some conversations and i just i
don't know where they are his parents
are
on this you know journey and so i just
kind of want to
i guess set a precedence of boundaries
yeah so so you don't have a relationship
with her number one
thanks for letting me laugh along with
you um i'm just projecting into the
future here
in my own house and so um i don't
i appreciate you letting us all walk
alongside you
and actually you went way ahead of us
all
we're just watching um and so in all
seriousness yeah i know this is hard
um yeah that's just hard and
so oh man
this one's kind of messy so you don't
know his parents you don't really have a
relationship with him
other than okay um i know him way better
than i know his parents he mostly comes
to our house
so she doesn't usually visit there and i
have just
you know seen his father in passing uh
pick up drop off
we have talked about having them over
for dinner and
honestly just never really got around to
it but now i know that absolutely needs
to happen now
so hey listen yeah
that would be the greatest parent
revenge dinner of all time
like we're gonna have his parents over
and we're all gonna talk about this
together
that would be the most legend baller
parent move of all time
if that happens record it because it
will be
a youtube sensation will pay your house
off it would be incredible
oh goodness man so oh yeah because how
old is this cat is he
16 too he's also 16 yeah okay so
this is one of those things that the
world has shifted a little bit
underneath
us if this had happened when i was 16
i feel like in that universe
parents trusted other parents to have
these type of conversations with their
kids
now we're in a world where i just don't
it doesn't it doesn't feel right to me
anymore
and so for you to go about talking to
him
now if he came over and you wanted to
address
the boundaries of your home i think
that's fully okay
um and so one would be a boundaries
conversation and one would might be the
moral character
like i'll tell this kid like not my
daughter that conversation right
right so backing out first and foremost
high five to you for raising a 16 year
old that y'all could have this
conversation it wasn't weird for y'all
no it really wasn't we actually laughed
more than it was awkward
so listen you're doing you were you were
way ahead of the curve
yeah it would have been more awesome if
you'd run in there screaming and yelling
and
throwing water on it whatever um but the
fact that you recognized i'm not going
to handle this well right this second
i'm going to let them know that i'm
going to put a stop to this by letting
them know
that i'm here and i know what's going on
and
i'm going to get control of my emotions
before i approach this good for you
high five to you that's awesome second
is both you and your husband address
this that's awesome and you addressed it
obviously in a way that
allowed for some levity and some
seriousness what i
often see people do is try to treat
their 16 year olds and 17 year olds and
18 year olds like their 10 year olds
right my 10 year old i can end your
world i can cut off your
communication in the outside world
16 year olds will go hook up in an
arby's parking lot right i mean it's a
different game unless you just say
you're homeschooling now you don't get
any electronics i'm going to cut you and
then
then you're on borrowed time right then
you're 700 days away from them saying
bye right yeah and so there there is a
that in my house these are my boundaries
these are my rules and
man you're if i'm gonna default to
relationship more than
than excommunication right that's a hard
the fishy scary boundary how'd your
husband handle this
um he surprisingly wasn't as upset as i
thought he would be
i talked to him about it first and then
we talked about it
and how we were gonna approach it with
her um we kind of made a game plan and
then we talked about it with her
um so we made sure that the other kids
were around and we had her by herself
and you know we just kind of brought it
up and you know just said okay we know
that something's happening i don't know
what the thing is but
there's some stuff happening and you
know we need to
talk about it and really talk about the
boundaries in our home
and you know where do we go from here
and the fact that you and your husband
put your heads together and talked about
it and came up with a plan that y'all
shared together i mean that's just
parent 101 you're
you're way far ahead good for you guys
so at the end of the day um
because he's a child this kid's a child
i would give his parents a heads up
um that's just me i'd call him and say
hey look this happened at our house
and we talked to our daughter about it
we like your son um
we don't hate him we don't think
anybody's evil but because they're kids
we thought it was right for you to know
and um i that's how i would handle this
again you never know what's coming
what's next
um they may say so
like they're 16 yeah or they may say oh
my gosh you're breaking up right away
and there's no communication ever you
never know how that's going to go
when it that's the the hard crappy part
about having boundaries is you can't be
responsible for other people's response
to your boundaries
right so one of my boundaries is if
there is a
child acting um
not being safe whether that's playing
out in the road
or um
whatever the thing happens to be i'm
going to bring the other parents into
the loop i'm just going to let them know
right again 20 30 years ago you had that
conversation
with the two of them and then it stays
there they still don't think we're there
anymore
and so i always want to make partners
with um other parents in my community
with kids
so i wouldn't hold on to that i would be
ready for the ramifications of that this
may all be fun and not fun in games but
relationship building your daughter got
to hear from you i think this is an
awesome opportunity for you not without
dad
to take daughter out and
you heard her so now it's time for her
to listen to you
and you can tell her about your teenage
years you can tell her about
your awkward experiences how
um even when you're married things you
can get off the rails and weird and hard
and
unexpected and awkward i think this is a
time for you
to really speak into that relationship
between you and your daughter i think
that could be a really
magic season for y'all and she is gonna
you can melt her and it's a i hope you
do right i hope you do
um but in a day you could call this
guy's parents and he could
get cut off and then your daughter's
gonna turn on you expect
that could happen and that doesn't mean
you did the wrong thing
okay um that means that his parents have
different values and different
boundaries than you guys do
and that's just part of it your
daughter's gonna you're playing a long
game with her now and she's gonna know
that you at the end of the day you're
doing what you could to keep her safe
and to keep her tethered to the values
that your family has whatever they may
be
i do have to know are you nervous about
that conversation you feel empowered
about it like
tell me about how that feels really
nervous about that conversation i don't
so tell me why i'm i honestly
i don't know that we have the same
values as in
i'm honestly worried that it's going to
be a so what
like no big deal um and then i will have
to put some really strong
firm boundaries about her visiting his
house
and so that is kind of what i am
concerned about he really
likes his family a lot and i think she
wants to continue
you know going there and you know
and trying to build that relationship
with his family but if they don't aren't
really on the same page
with values then i feel like i should
not let her
go there if that makes sense
i think this is a really pivotal time
for you
and your daughter's relationship i
wholeheartedly support you
your values are your values and if you
don't want her in an unsafe situation
then that's your right as a parent
and um i i hope
and i know this is easier said than done
i hope that you will
always feel affirmed in your parent
values whatever they happen to be
and i hope you will always default to
relationship too
which it sounds like y'all clearly have
but if you have to draw some boundaries
and say the only time you can see this
this boy are at my at our house
and if you violate those then it's not
going to be that
you saw this boy it's that now we can't
trust you because we put a boundary up
whatever that happened to be
and you violated the boundary then it's
not about the the
action number one it's about number two
right um this is an important season for
you guys
a really important season and so for
whatever it's worth
um from the outside it sounds like you
guys are handling this with the right
amount of humor
and grace and communication
in your marriage with your kids good for
you guys all the way across
my hope is that 20 years from now she's
married to some knucklehead and this
becomes a hilarious
thanksgiving story i'll tell over and
over
and that this becomes a really
remarkable time that you can teach her
about valuing herself and what love
looks like
and how messy relationships can get
and because you've walked there right
and that can be a
really vulnerable honest time between
you and her
and it could get really off the rails
and so if it gets off the rails
i hope that you will continue to loop
back to your default this first time
around
which is i'm going to make sure my
husband and i are on the same page
we're always going to we're going to
head into these these value
conversations together
we're gonna make sure we're not putting
our daughter on blast in front of our
other kids
unless it's really funny then it's gotta
come up at the dinner table
for sure um but
that you and you're continuing to honor
her in that relationship how she chooses
to revolt and
throw her 16 year old fits against up
and up and down against your boundaries
that's her deal that's what 16 year olds
do
right that doesn't mean you're wrong or
out of whack or out of balance
20 years from now she'll think you have
five ten years from now she'll thank you
but
yeah you said it best six-month
relationships are a thousand-year
marriages to 16-year-olds
everything's the most dramatic thing
ever and oh my gosh you took away my
love
um so here high five to you parent to
parent way to go mary
but yeah i'd make that conversation i'd
have that conversation
and um i would i wouldn't
i wouldn't i would do my best to not let
my heart rate get up
one beat extra you have nothing to be
ashamed about your values are your
values
you've got nothing to um
the unknown is the unknown but you're
doing the right thing good for you
well thank you so much i appreciate your
help and your insight to some
it's just i don't know it's just kind of
messy it feels really overwhelming so
it does and tell tell let your daughter
in on that too
okay and when you say hey
you're still a child you're a kid she'll
be like no i'm 16. i can drive and i
can hook up with my boyfriend when you
guys are out in the yard i can do
whatever i want like
yeah i know and you're still 16. right
and that's
it's so hard you might as well start
telling her how i used to go uphill in
the snow
to school both ways it's it's like that
you're in that territory
back when i was a kid metallica was
really heavy battle you're i know you
all sound like that but
um those conversations and that that
continuing to go back to relationship
back to relationship back to values back
to values back to relationship
trump's everything good for you good for
you
um hey if you will do me a huge favor
this isn't for the audience it's just
for me personally
i have to know how that conversation
goes so if you'll write back
um and let us know how it goes or call
back and leave a message
and if it's a disaster if they did heard
that guy's dad just starts laughing at
you you idiot what a nerd
let me know that too um then he'll be an
idiot but
um anyway give me a call back i gotta
know how this ends
uh but thank you so much for the call
mary
i just got so many feelings on this
i have so many feelings i have so many
jokes that i want to make
i have so many things that i want to
announce to 16 year olds that i'm not
going to announce
oh my gosh dude my kids are eleven and
five i'm not ready for this james
we need to we need to produce a
subscriber
paid subscription podcast version where
you just say
what's exactly yeah we could make a
fortune it only last two episodes before
we got canceled but it would be
spectacular
it would be spectacular